you are watching the press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive it's time to see what's
making the headlines with writer and
broadcaster mohir bose and the economist
senior editor and mckell boy they'll be
with us right through until midnight
so let's see what's on some of those
front pages for you now and the times
leads with news that the plymouth gunman
jake davidson had his gun licence
returned to him last month after it was
revoked over an assault allegation
that's also the lead in the telegraph
with a picture of the three-year-old
victim sophie martin and her father
the guardian's front carries this same
photo of sophie and her father with the
headline police face inquiry over mass
killer's gun license
likewise the male which calls him a
killer virgin who was frustrated at his
lack of success with women
the financial times leads with the
growing taliban takeover of afghanistan
with the country's second city already
fallen and the capital kabul surrounded
warning over chaotic deals on devolution
is the headline of the yorkshire post
they say that 6.5 million people in the
north are missing out on the benefits
due to regional inequalities
and the daily star leads with a story
about weight gain in those under 60 with
the headline it's not your metabolism
now we're joined tonight by writer and
broadcaster mahir bose and the economist
senior editor and mikhail welcome to you
both good evening let's start with the
times front page and that headline gun
license given back to killer weeks
before the attack uh attention's turning
to the investigation as to how that that
decision was made and and why anne
absolutely i mean there's a
heartbreaking front pages on this story
and there's image of the little girl who
was one of the victims i'm sure it's
just
incredibly upsetting to see
the bigger policy question of course is
what was going on about the gun
licensing and why someone who clearly
you had the problems that he was known
to have
um or at least you know was suspected to
to be
unstable and to have
been accused of assault before was able
to get the license back so quickly and
there has to be some questions about
that because obviously a lot of licenses
are revoked and given back and sometimes
mistakes will occur but with a tragedy
of this scale i think that there will be
a major overhaul of this process
yes um here questions will be asked as
to to whether the police were aware of
his uh mental health state and whether
questions were asked in that respect
yes and and the report in the papers at
the times and so on talks that uh the
gun license was given back uh after he
went on an anger management course and
this sounds like a box sticking exercise
i mean to do
this reduces it to the level that if
you're caught speeding you go on a
driving driving port in order to avoid
points i mean how was this done why was
this done and i think the other question
is that um uh you know how much uh
tracking is done i mean this was a man
who did not hide his views i mean he
made a lot of online statements
ramblings about this in cell misogynist
movement of voluntary celibate men who
blame women for everything what was done
to sort of track it you know i mean
and and i think what is really worrying
is um is that we seem to be getting
closer and closer to to america in the
sense that we have these killings they
have been in cell killings in america
and in japan and so on and that would be
really the very worrying thing if we are
now trying if we are getting to that
state it suggests that we need better
controls about monitoring these things
yes and the daily telegraph and they
they actually name him as an incel
killer um and give a bit more detail as
to this group and what what their
beliefs are
yes i mean this is an extreme form of
misogyny and people who are already
having great difficulties or he
experienced great difficulties in his
dealings with women with his family but
of course there are a lot of people in
that position you know who would not
ever dream of resorting to this kind of
random and terrible
violence that the problem with something
like intel which i think is still not
very well understood in in britain and
is one of the the darker areas of the
internet and social media groups because
we don't really know much about its
scale it is something that isn't here
right he says has been on on the radar
in this state
and in japan
it can often just be people saying very
very unpleasant things and
if you think about your views of hate
speech and how far you want to go in
saying that that should in itself be
illegal but the difficulty i would guess
is if you you can monitor it but then
trying to put together a picture of who
is likely to act on it in a way that
could be a danger to the public is a
much much greater and difficult task to
that extent it's a bit akin to counter
terrorism in the broader sense of the
word it's a needle in a haystack but
there definitely are needles and then in
this case it's done the most immense
damage
does this raise questions again about
social media and how it's policed and
perhaps warning signals might have been
picked up a lot earlier before that this
tragedy occurred
yes it certainly raises the entire
question about um social media um
outlets what they do how they are how
they are regulated and we know this this
debate has been ongoing um uh on various
aspects that it has been going on in in
in football with uh
racist messages and so on and in various
other aspects and and the government has
proposed legislation on this but the
social media um organizations near
really need to be held accountable for
what is on their sides you know i mean
that that goes without without doubt and
clearly because of the the the internet
that we have which is such a worldwide
channel one doesn't know how jake
davidson
acquired his thoughts and ideas and so
on but one can imagine that because of
the insult movement existing in other
parts of the world um the message of
this was easily spread and then we've
got to find a way of trying to in some
way regulating it without restricting
free speech i mean that is always a
consideration but otherwise i think that
this is the sort of killing that that
could take place um unfortunately again
yes
very depressing uh prospect um also the
question is as to how easy is it to to
get a gun and to get a gun license and a
22 year old seemingly facing no
difficulty in acquiring the firearm
yes i think that that is
definitely something that that will come
out of the inevitable inquiry into this
hair was he able to get a gun i i think
what a lot of people obviously you have
guns for for reasons that are legitimate
for hunting particularly in sports we
don't thank goodness we haven't reached
a point where people resort to guns for
self-defense very much in this country
remember that gun crime is still very
low in britain compared to a lot of
other major democracies
to me the question is this
i think what happened for a long time
that was a view that you would take guns
away from people if there were any
question marks over their behavior if
you would then go through a process
where you have to prove that you were a
stable individual and you got the gun
back but there is a sense here i think
we used the words that box ticking
exercise earlier on and that may well
turn out to have been the case certainly
it was a misreading of this personal
state of mind with disastrous
consequences so i think we're almost
looking at two things how people get
guns in the first place and what is the
process
by which they get them back again that
seems to be to me where the big failure
has taken place
yes and here that as the the guardian
says the inquiry um is underway and we
must wait for the the outcome of that to
find out you know what some of those
questions hopefully will will be
answered
yes and i hope the inquiry will be a
thorough one i mean uh what and says is
is is perfectly true and valid and one
thing fact that this is now more than
what a quarter of a century ago we had
dumbling and we had a lot of debate then
legislation and so on and we need to
look at why since then if anything um
gun crime has increased in this country
and why it has done so because we used
to be very proud of the fact that um
that gun crime as such was not a problem
our policemen have never carried guns
and so on and now it seems to be a
problem in this country although not
quite america thank goodness but
nevertheless why is this happening and
what needs to be done with gun
legislation at the whole idea of of
requiring guns in this country
and i mean the only person on the street
that will see acquiring a gun as
something that that's
really quite difficult
to to do i mean what is the the
procedure how how clear are you on on
how easy it is to to acquire firearms
well the system works really on
background check
it says well what is the purpose
obviously for which you wish to acquire
this weapon and particularly in the uk
context unless you
are allowed to carry a professional
purposes because it's your your job to
be armed in some way and that's a
relatively small group of people very
tightly monitored
then it works by saying well
you are applying for a gun because you
wanted the sporting hunting purposes
and we will have a look at you and there
is supposed to be rather sophisticated
testing that that goes into that the
problem is that if you have someone
who's really determined to acquire a gun
and with the intention to use it for
wrong purposes and either because you
want to threaten people or because you
ought to be unstable and you you want to
branch a gun about the worst case
analysis like this that you use it
these are people who are not likely to
go through the process in good faith
they don't fill out the information
correctly and unless they come onto the
radar of the authorities that that
there's checks on that i think are
probably not as deep as they should be
it would be i think stating the obvious
that that something like that is going
to be the conclusion here but what we
really need to look at is what happened
on the second occasion there are
allegations results against this man i
don't entirely agree with me here by the
way that censoring the internet is the
way to go on this you you there's just
so much kind of rubbish nonsense and
bile sprouted on the internet if you're
going to go close down you've closed
down all of it you know
it is really not the task that is
possible and in some ways it's not
desirable because you have to
distinguish between people saying stupid
things which are well entitled to do and
things which are directly threatening
that's actually difficult
and i think like where you go from this
is you just have to tighten the
background check i think we'll see a
major campground i've no doubt about
that front page and afghanistan um and
that story obviously has been uh
uppermost in people's minds with the
situation at the moment and the taliban
gaining ground at an alarming rate uh
the the suspicion is that uh kabul could
fall uh imminently and
it does look that way doesn't it i think
one thing that has
taken a lot of senior military figures
by surprise particularly in the u.s
after the joe biden announcement early
in his presidency that he he wanted to
pull back quickly from afghanistan was
the ferocity of which taliban forces
have been able to sweep all before them
and the rather disorganized uh afghan
army despite the best attempt
particularly for british military
americans and and others
to train them and to to ready them for a
taliban assault this isn't just clearly
not worked and i think the questions are
several obviously the deeper one
was it ever was to be in afghanistan in
the first place but i do think also some
criticism needs to be leveled at joe
biden here i mean this looked like
something that he he wanted to achieve
in a tearing hurry in his presidency to
show that he was going to disentangle
america from this military engagement
but the consequences will be absolutely
devastating for afghanistan and not only
that it will be another way that
refugees which will then sweep from
afghanistan of course and in into to
europe and that will start another cycle
of
of bitterness and debate about what
earth has been going on so all in all it
looks like a massive policy failure i
know british senior military figures did
not approve of it but there was very
little that could be done uh once joe
biden had his his mind set on it uh and
yet
we hear from joe biden himself that he
doesn't regret withdrawing the troops
from afghanistan
yes i think joe biden has made mistakes
but frankly if you look at afghanistan
this has been a western mistake in
afghanistan going back decades you know
the west has completely always misread
afghanistan it went in after 9 11 saying
it has got to attack al-qaeda then it
said it's going to create a new
afghanistan
recall how ahmed karzai was was treated
in fact the clothes he wore was treated
by gucci as the most fashion statement
and and what what do we have this
morning ben wilson going on radio giving
us a history lesson which suggested that
he would get a e in in history if he
started his a levels and and and you
know
now he says we can't change the culture
in afghanistan the west went in the west
couldn't even get afghanistan and
pakistan to come to terms the two
countries absolutely hate each other so
there's been a colossal number of
failures and at the moment the taliban
is running rings around the west they
are holding talks at the moment in doha
with all the western countries and and
india china and pakistan talking about a
ceasefire and and you know
this there's been a colossal western
failure which goes beyond by to a long
period of time
uh the telegraph uh looking at it from
another point of view suggesting that um
the prime minister is saying that
british troops didn't die in vain we've
heard from one father who lost his son
in helmand and saying the complete
opposite that it seems that the
sacrifice was for nothing
well i i mean of course people will have
very strong feelings and if they've lost
people in service in afghanistan they'll
be very entitled to feel very bitter and
wonder what on earth
has this come to i would see it in a
slightly more nuanced way there was a
reason to go in after 9 11 in order to
target al-qaeda i think i don't entirely
take the sweeping view that here takes i
think that really what happened was you
had a kind of mission creep and you had
a
view at the time liberal interventionism
was at its peak that not only could you
sort of get in and get out and deal with
the al-qaeda problem which was that was
a genuine uh